foreign
good news everyone there's a new acronym
in town and it's the trendiest one on
the market right now the website pop
sugar where I go for all the most
important news has the story about those
living the d-i-n-k lifestyle dink
so it says quote in the United States a
growing number of couples live a dink
lifestyle instead of the historically
traditional family structure that
includes having children at least
according to data the dink lifestyle AKA
dual income no kids is generally used to
describe a family where neither adult in
the partnership has children and both
are working paying jobs according to the
latest data from the U.S Census Bureau
the number of adults living without
children has increased by 19 since 1967.
in addition a 2021 Pew Research Center
survey found 44 of non-parents between
the ages of 18 and 49 say it's unlikely
they will have children the figure is up
from 37 in 2018 indicating a growing
trend of couples delaying having kids or
foregoing them all together
several factors that contribute to the
rise of the uh dink lifestyle including
a delay in median age at the time of
marriage financial reasons and shifts in
life goals
now apparently dink isn't technically
new the acronym was coined I guess in
the 80s from what I understand but has
become more popular recently and it's
only further proof proof of the age-old
saying that I just made up which is this
just because you can make something into
an acronym doesn't mean you should
dink sounds like some kind of slur you
know it's like not a label that people
willingly apply to themselves yet still
I must admit that the name seems to fit
the people who have embraced it
this is one dumb trendy acronym that I
will happily use use if you want to be
called a dink I will call you a dink
in fact for my brief research online I
discovered that there are subsets within
the dink Community for instance there
are I'm not making this up
there are people who apparently call
themselves dink wads
dual income no kids with a dog denkwad
once again I concede that dink wad okay
that the dink wads have chosen a name
which fits them perfectly
childless people with with dogs pink
wads
so what you want to identify yourself as
I will happily call you that
and I will encourage others to do the
same
so going back to the article we're given
more specific information about these
dinks and Dink wads it says quote like
any partnership in family structure the
dink lifestyle isn't a one-size-fits-all
term instead couples come to live the
dink lifestyle for various reasons Jay
zigmont PhD and founder of child free
wealth in Water Valley Mississippi tells
pop sugar for Zig Mont and his wife the
dink lifestyle provided more flexibility
in creating a life that works best for
them which he's also seen with many of
his clients Sigmund says that his in his
experience those who choose to live a
dink lifestyle do so for three main
reasons they never wanted children their
Finance they are focused on financial
wellness and they desire freedom
there's another recent article this uh
this one on Yahoo and written by a dink
and it goes into more detail about the
reasons why the dinks decide to be such
dinks it says quote we've all seen the
means and even the bumper stickers
colorful displays proclaiming I am a
Funko or celebrating being Mom to fur
babies only there are countless ways
some share that they're enthusiastically
certain they're living their best life
thanks to being Child free and once and
once these happy Souls of which I am one
find a partner there's another term that
comes into play dink I'm a proud dink my
husband and I are both in our late 30s
and have chosen the dink life and no we
aren't those married to our career types
while we both enjoy success in our
fields we enjoy a deep bond that I can't
imagine would be possible if I had to
give so much of myself to caring for a
child we are not selfish individuals but
instead selfish with the time we have
together for the sake of our
relationship
we're then given other examples from the
dink Community to show that there are
many and varied reasons why a dink might
choose to be a dank it says
in recent times I've discovered that
we're not alone in addition to Circles
of friends that share this similar
mindset there's an entire online
community dedicated to removing the
pressures and stigmatism surrounding the
subject danaya casalis a 33 year old
microbiologist an online fitness coach
resides in Florida with her partner
together they've created a space and a
safe and inspiring space on Instagram
for others like them to share the daily
humorous and often reluctant encounters
they face as dinks quote I knew in my
early 20s that I for sure had no desire
to have kids casellas tells Yahoo life I
don't get excited over babies but I'm
good with kids I have a silly
personality and enjoy being around them
but taking on the huge responsibility of
raising someone just doesn't appeal to
me I was told I was crazy selfish and
that I would regret it I'm now 33 Child
free and living my best life
the best life she speaks of Casella
spent years living in New York City on a
journey of self-discovery and she and
her partner now enjoy the spontaneity
that dink life brings like making last
minute dinner plans playing in soccer
leagues and taking trips to Universal
Studios Orlando
now every example in the article is like
this it turns out that there are not
actually many in varied reasons why
people become dinks all the reasons are
basically the same they want more money
they want more time to go on vacation
and they want fewer responsibilities
and that basically sums it up it is
rather revealing that even in these
propaganda pieces and I've read a lot of
them designed to promote the child-free
life rarely do you hear about someone
who uses their quote freedom to go on
great Heroic Adventures you know nor do
you hear about them devoting their free
time to serving their communities nor
any other worthy Pursuit
instead they just buy more stuff and
they take sad little childless trips to
theme parks and they eat at restaurants
more often
so they dedicate themselves to being
more active and more loyal consumers in
other words
that's what it always comes down to
they choose to not have kids so that
they can consume more and become more
devoted consumers
look your best this holiday season with
genucel skin care now through Christmas
genucel's most popular package is 70 off
this includes two months worth of a
geniusell's best sellers plus their
hyaluronic let's call it acid serum free
with your purchase my producer McKenna
uses genucel under eye treatment to help
her get rid of the bags under her eyes
genucel uses a proprietary base with
clinical levels of Botanical extracts
which come together to yield amazing
results genital products are natural
cruelty free and made in the USA treat
yourself and a loved one to the skin
care that will take years off your skin
watch those forehead wrinkles Fine Lines
skin redness pesky bags and puffiness
disappear right before your eyes with
genucel's most popular collection you'll
see immediate effects in less than 12
hours guaranteed or your money back so
visit general.com Welsh use code walls
for an additional 10 off your order plus
every order is instantly upgraded to
free express shipping that's genucel.com
geniusell.com Welsh
for all the high-minded theoretical talk
about what a child-free quote-unquote
life could free a person up to do
this is what they actually do this is
what it actually means they're not
trudging through unexplored parts of the
Amazon or inventing a cure for cancer or
building homes for poor villagers in
Namibia or whatever they are rather far
more focused on entertaining themselves
and their Adventures of exploration will
generally be relegated to tourist spots
that have already been explored by
approximately 900 million people before
them that's the reality
and this is the problem
with the dink life one of the problems
anyway
and we must as always stipulate though
it should be clear by now that we're
talking about couples who choose not to
have children okay not those who want to
but are unable
the issue is the lifestyle choice
and the first way you can tell that a
lifestyle choice is problematic
is by extending its logic as far as it
will go
so the dinks say that dink life is good
and Noble and it's wonderful and and and
you know and and all that something to
be proud of
yet if everyone chose to be Dinks human
civilization would quickly collapse and
in less than a century our species will
go extinct
so if everyone chose to be dinks like
today
within 20 years there is no civilization
anymore it's it collapses it's so
top-heavy that it would just fall over
on itself and you know a few more
decades it's extinct
so if your lifestyle Choice can only be
adopted by a relatively small percentage
of the most privileged members of the
human race or else civilizational
catastrophe would ensue that's a pretty
good indication that there's something
wrong with your lifestyle choice
okay and that and that applies across
the board
if your lifestyle choice
cannot be adopted by very many people or
else it will destroy the the human race
then there's probably something wrong
at the very least it proves beyond a
shadow of a doubt that your lifestyle is
not one we should recommend
because again if too many people took us
up on the recommendation the human race
disappears
so there are those who are doing the
work to ensure that our race survives
and thrives and there are those more
interested in taking trips to Universal
Studios those two choices are not equal
by any objective measure
but the truth is that the dink approach
does plenty of damage even before it can
get to the point of causing a mass
extinction event
the point is that when we encourage
people to get married and have children
we are encouraging them to look towards
the future
and to live lives of love and service
not every parent is gonna you know live
up to this calling of course you could
be a parent and still be a selfish uh
SOB that's for sure but at least as a
culture we are pointing people in the
right direction
the other option is to point people
towards lives centered around themselves
their own Comfort luxury entertainment
that's no way to build or maintain a
thriving Society
and on an individual level it's a recipe
for a life that while comfortable
is ultimately empty and purposeless
purposeless
you know the consequence of being
sentient self-aware relatively
intelligent creatures is that is that we
cannot help but search for meaning
no other creature as far as we know on
Earth is bothered by this detail
so great white sharks aren't reflecting
on the meaning of it all as they hunt
and devour a seal ants aren't wondering
what it all means as they swarm over a
melting popsicle left in the pavement
only we are left with these questions
and we cannot Escape them
and what we find ultimately is that
momentary pleasures and Amusements
cannot satisfy our need and longing for
meaning
they can only distract us from them but
not forever
not for long
family life gives us purpose and meaning
and even that is an ultimate meeting in
and of itself our ultimate meaning our
ultimate purpose is to know God love him
and serve him but family life points Us
in that direction towards the Eternal
and the transcendental it grounds Us in
something that goes beyond transcends
self-service and self-satisfaction
and the cost of that
is that we can't take as many vacations
but that is a price well worth paying
and it's why today I must say
both the dinks and the denquads are
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows and move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]